[Music]
ernest is in kansas city hi ernest how
are you
doing pretty good dave how are you
better than i deserve how can we help
uh hi i was just wondering what can i do
to
kind of protect the money we've saved
from inflation
saved where is it saved
uh we're just in savings accounts
basically right now
how much is in there investment
uh 10 000 in the house fund
about 20 000 in the emergency fund okay
the emergency fund you don't protect
from inflation that's not what it's for
it's there just for insurance so when
life happens
transmission goes out somebody gets sick
somebody gets laid off
that's what it's for it's not it's not
an investment investments have to be
protected from inflation
by investing at a rate of return
that is higher than the inflation rate
and that's what you have to do you have
to make the inflation rate is average in
the last 72 years 4.2 percent
taxes added about another two percent to
that so you got to make over six percent
on your money on a long-term investment
to break even with taxes and inflation
and that's always been the case these uh
increases in prices have kind of
recently in cars and houses and building
supplies and other stuff has woke people
up again
on the dangers of inflation but
inflation's always been there to erode
your long-term investing
if you don't do that and so in other
words if you put money in a cd
for 50 years at one or two percent
and inflation is running 4 obviously
you're going backwards and that's not
handling your money well but your
emergency fund is not for that your
house fund is going to be spent as a
down payment on your house in the next
couple of years
right potentially
yeah so inflation is not going to eat
that up because it's not going to be in
there long enough
where inflation gets you is where you're
dealing with something that's a 10
a 20 a 40 year investment that's where
inflation gets you it doesn't get you in
12 months
okay that makes sense to you it makes
sense yeah
just house prices have jumped up this
year car prices have jumped up
but that's not going to be a standard
way we're not going to see house prices
go up 20
a year for 10 years just wouldn't it's
just not going to happen if it does
we've got other
issues in this economy and they're
that's just structurally not how we're
wired in america
i just do not see that happening but
could we see it for
coming off the pandemic can we see some
of these things bump temporarily
you bet we have car prices are an
example of that
um and it's all it's more due to
shortages than it is anything else and
once the supply demand
curves equal out it's going to slow the
rate
of these price increases it's not a
bubble and it's not going to burst and
it's not going to go backward 50
or something like that 5 years from now
that's not what it's going to do
but this driving demand people sat
at home and spent no money except on
amazon for a year
and when they came out of their cave
they all went and bought a stinking
house
and they all went bought a stinking car
by the way the lumber factories weren't
open making two befores
and the car factories weren't open
making cars so
we have this tremendous shortage of
supply
because the factories weren't operating
because there were little covets running
around in the factories and nobody
wanted to go in there
and so they were you know scared of
death and so we shut the factories down
we suppressed
the economy and that you know so there's
a shortage
of two befores not because there's this
spike of demand
but because they weren't making freaking
tubaphores
there's a shortage of glue to make
plywood
why because there's a big run on plywood
no because the clue factory wasn't open
okay it's a simple thing so it's gonna
smooth out
because they're gearing up like crazy
there's a shortage on ammunition you
know why
biden you can't buy bullets
okay it's why and you know what we're
having all kinds those of us that are
firearms uh
aficionados right now we're having to
check our
ammo because they're making ammo so
freaking fast at these factories trying
to catch up
that it's a lot of it's coming out
defective which is dangerous as crud you
can blow your gun up in your hand with a
bad piece of
bullet in there and so you know just got
an email on that this morning some
friends of mine just bought some bad
stuff and just about got killed with it
so um you know you but the point is the
factories are gearing up like crazy
trying to catch up
and as they catch up you see how it's
working again it's going to smooth
everything out well i just what people
understand inflation can get really
scary to people and remember the media
exists to freak you out
okay that's what they're all talking
about trust me it's everywhere
in big bold letters if you listen close
enough dave you lean in you can
literally hear the headline going
and we're just freaking people out
here's the deal all right this is a
short-term
inflationary well like the other bookies
so now we have to have a new boogie
monster the
so now they gotta have a new bug boogie
monster let's see where we are next year
as to whether or not this is true
inflation hike versus just a short-term
spike because of the whole supply-demand
thing this thing is going to even back
out i absolutely think that's true
and people need to relax a little bit
sit tight weather the spike in
meat prices and all the things that are
that are
all having to do with the distribution
system
and everything kind of going offline
it's going to take a while
this was the biggest artificial shutdown
in
the history of mankind of mankind and so
you don't just warm that machine back
up it takes a little while for it to get
humming well and some of these
uh corporations are more worried about
optics than they are actually absolutely
true and so they're not reopening just
because one
crazy you know activists or something is
gonna
[ __ ] about being open people on twitter
yeah there's 17 people on twitter still
bitching about
this stuff and so they're all worried
about how things look you know how they
actually are they're not really worried
about somebody they're sick they're
worried about somebody bitching about
them being open that's right
that's what it is and so um these
corporations have no soul and they have
no principles no backbone
and so then that's what's happened in
these situations
and um and of course those of us that
did open
and did run our businesses we're trying
to kill our employees
oh yeah you know dave ramsey's trying to
kill his employees oh yeah so
which is kind of counterproductive
because i've got no employees i got to
go re-hire them all it's a pain in the
butt
so it's killing them off's a problem you
don't want to kill them off they're hard
to replace
dumb so that's what's going on though
man all right so ernest
turn off the news yes turn off the news
quit getting your financial advice from
fox news yeah
quick in your financial advice from cnn
for god's sakes those people on the tv
in front of you all have 120 000
student loan debt so don't let them talk
to you about economics yeah and they
don't even know what inflation is it's
only on the prompter in front of them
that's a fact they don't even know what
inflation you're seeing anchorman
whatever's there they read right you're
getting financial advice from ron
burgundy
what's wrong with this picture right
he doesn't even know it's just on the
problem
yeah and here's here's the scarier part
let's dave let's give him full behind
the scenes
not only is it ron burgundy reading
something on a prompter a 24 to 25 year
old producer typed it in there for him
yeah they don't understand economics or
inflation
see i'm old i remember jimmy carter i
remember real inflation
right that was real inflation that was
not a supply demand curve
thrown off by a pandemic that's right
economic suppression
that is that's a different thing we had
bad
monetary policy over a decade yes from
the 70s up into the 80s and we were
jamming at 10 to 15 percent inflation
rate per year for a decade there yeah
i remember this interest rates at the
height of that do you remember
that was the resulting thing that that
ended the carter administration for sure
yeah we had when i uh was 20
let's see 1981
interest i was 21 interest i was selling
real estate interest rates for a home
or 17 goodness crisis fixed rate
17 and uh that was the end of it
and and let me just here's the
interesting thing three years earlier
they were 10. yeah wow
when i when i got my license at 18 years
old in september
i remember it went from nine and three
quarters to ten for the first time
in modern history we had ten percent
mortgage rates and people were screaming
ready to jump out of windows sure that
the world was coming to an end
and little did they know it was going
from 10 to 17 in only about 36 months
yeah just crazy yeah that's
real inflation you don't have to worry
about on the short term brother
you just don't have to worry about the
short term it's a long term where
inflation will kill you